El Kremlin está crujiendo por dentro.
El intento de golpe de Estado del grupo
Wagner encabezado por Yevgeny Prigozhin
ha dejado muy tocado a Vladímir Putin.
Por primera vez ha quedado claro que el
presidente ruso ya no es un tipo tan fuerte ni
su gobierno tiene tanto control como antaño.
En poco más de un año Vladímir Putin ha pasado
de ser un líder fuerte y temido, prácticamente el
nuevo Zar de Rusia, a convertirse en una especie
de líder paría de un país que se cae a pedazos:
La guerra va mal, las bajas se
acumulan y ahora los señores de
la guerra se atreven incluso a retar al Kremlin.
Seamos honestos, hace 2 años este escenario nos
hubiera parecido completamente descabellado.
Pero cuando te lanzas a una guerra como la de
Ucrania, si no la ganas, entonces puedes tener
muchos problemas. A nadie le gusta perder y, no lo
dudéis, siempre tiene que haber un culpable. Por
eso aquí en VisualPolitik ya os contamos cómo tras
los fracasos y el esfuerzo de Rusia en la guerra
contra Japón y también en la I guerra Mundial,
se produjo la revolución de febrero de 1917.
Y no. No estamos hablando de la revolución
bolchevique. Hablamos de la que tuvo lugar
meses antes. Que no fue una revolución comunista,
sino una revolución liberal. Cuando estalló, el
zar intentó sofocar la revuelta por la fuerza,
pero las guarniciones militares de San Petersburgo
se sublevaron y desobedecieron las órdenes
recibidas. Una semana después, Nicolás II abdicó.
¿Veis algún paralelismo?
Vale que el grupo Wagner no es el ejército,
y que de momento el presidente de Rusia no
ha tenido que abdicar, pero es evidente que
los paralelismos están sobre la mesa. Y ojo,
no lo decimos nosotros, lo dijo el
propio Putin en el mensaje a la nación
que pronunció mientras el golpe de mano de
Yevgeny Prigozhin estaba en marcha. Fijaos.
Pero, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
de todo esto ya os hablamos específicamente
en un vídeo que os dejamos en la descripción.
Pero los acontecimientos nos obligan
a hacernos unas cuantas preguntas.
¿Cómo podría ser una Rusia post-Putin? ¿Quién
podría sustituirlo en el cargo? ¿Qué consecuencias
políticas puede tener el pulso hecho de los
Wagner? ¿Realmente ha podido debilitar a
Putin si al final parece que todo quedó en nada?
La revolución de 1917 no es el
único paralelismo histórico que
podemos encontrar con la situación actual.
Existe otro acontecimiento mucho
más reciente que nos recuerda
mucho a todo lo que estamos viviendo
tras el fracaso de Rusia en Ucrania.
Prestad mucha atención.
Por cierto, si te gusta lo que hacemos
y quieres ayudarnos a crecer, puedes
sumarte a nuestra comunidad de Patreon. Además de
contribuir con este proyecto recibirás también un
montón de contenido extra, como el boletín “Las
Claves de la Semana” y merchandising exclusivo.
Muchas gracias a los que ya nos echáis
una mano formando parte de esta comunidad.
Y ahora sí, continuemos. Vamos
a ver un poco de historia
T1 (LA CAÍDA DEL IMPERIO ROJO)
Si algo nos dicen la historia de Rusia es
que en este país los cambios de gobierno
y la lucha por la influencia política no
suelen ser acontecimientos nada tranquilos:
Conspiraciones, envenenamientos,
muertes extremadamente casuales,
golpes de Estado y muchas traiciones.
Tenemos ejemplos para todos los gustos.
Desde la expulsión de Trotsky a
manos de Stalin a la destitución
de Jrushchov promovida por Leonid
Brézhnev o el calvario que vivió
Gorbachov y que terminó provocando el
fin de la mismísima Unión Soviética.
Echemos un vistazo a este último caso. En 1991
la Unión Soviética estaba en crisis. El imperio
comunista parecía cada vez más agotado. El
entonces líder soviético, Mijaíl Gorbachov,
había iniciado un proceso de reforma que
incluía la aprobación Perestroika, esto es,
la reestructuración económica, y también
de la Glásnost, la apertura política.
(Estos cambios fueron toda una revolución.
Pusieron punto final a muchos de los cimientos
del viejo modelo soviético, lo que,
por supuesto, no gustó a todo el mundo.
Muchos miembros del Partido Comunista, del
Ejército y de los servicios de inteligencia
vieron estos cambios como una traición
a los principios soviéticos. Y como,
además, la población estaba sufriendo una durísima
crisis económica, los rusos tampoco parecían
particularmente emocionados con Gorbachov.)
Amigos, el modelo hacía aguas y en agosto de
1991 un grupo de altos funcionarios conocidos
como "El Comité Estatal de Emergencia" intentó
dar un golpe de Estado para tomar las riendas,
deshacer las reformas de Gorbachov
y volver al viejo modelo soviético.
Sin embargo, a pesar de que el golpe
tenía bastantes apoyos dentro del estado,
al final fracasó. El entonces vicepresidente
ruso, Boris Yeltsin, jugó un papel fundamental
para que el golpe no triunfara. Subido
literalmente en un tanque, llamó a la
resistencia civil contra el golpe. Los moscovitas
respondieron y el golpe fracasó en 3 días.
Pese a ello, el poder de Gorbachov había sido
gravemente diezmado. Tanto que en los meses
siguientes las diferentes repúblicas que
conformaban la URSS empezaron a pasar de
Moscú y al final, el 26 de diciembre de ese
mismo año, apenas 4 meses después del golpe,
se produjo la disolución de la Unión
Soviética. El Imperio rojo era ya historia.
Sí, el golpe del 19 de agosto fracasó,
pero al mismo tiempo terminó por provocar
el hundimiento completa de la mismísima
Unión de Repúblicas Socialistas Soviéticas.
Pues bien, el caso es que ahora, en
tiempos también muy difíciles para Rusia,
se ha producido la primera insurrección armada
contra Putin. Un intento de golpe de Estado que
parece haber fracasado… Pero, ¿Realmente ha
sido así? ¿Hasta qué punto está en riesgo la
continuidad de Vladímir Putin? ¿Estamos ante un
escenario similar al dele golpe fracaso de 1991?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2 (EL MERCENARIO QUE APUNTA ALTO)
De momento el primer envite contra Vladímir
Putin ya se ha producido. Lo ha liderado
este hombre que veis en pantalla y
que estoy seguro, ya todos conocéis:
Yevgeny Prigozhin, el fundador y
líder del grupo de mercenarios Wagner.
Un tipo que hasta la guerra de Ucrania
era un completo desconocido… Al menos para
el gran público. Prigozhin es un viejo
aliado de Putin que durante los últimos
se ha dedicado a desarrollar una enorme
red de tentáculos al servicio de Putin.
(Por ejemplo, cuando el presidente
ruso lanzó su invasión de Ucrania,
quiso asegurarse que la guerra no creara héroes
nacionales capaces de rivalizar con su figura.
De esta forma, cuando en el verano del 2022 el
general Alexander Lapin empezó a ser relativamente
popular, automáticamente se lo quitaron
de en medio. Para desacreditarle en redes,
Putin recurrió al grupo Wagner, que además
de repartir mercenarios por el mundo,
también tiene una importante división para
propagar fake news y librar la guerra mediática.)
Luego, cuando el ejército ruso estaba
completamente atascado y era incapaz de
lograr ninguna victoria en Ucrania, Putin
recurrió otra vez a los Wagner para que
lograran hacerse con Soledad primero y
con Bahamut despues. Cosa que hicieron.
C1 (“Wagner fue el único elemento exitoso
de la invasión rusa durante un año. Y su
éxito fue muy limitado y se centró en
una pequeña ciudad y sus tácticas fueron
bárbaras incluso para el personal de Wagner.
Pero al menos lograron algo. El ejército
ruso no podía”. Andriy Zagorodnyuk,
exministro de defensa de Ucrania)
El caso, y esto es quizás lo más sorprendente de
toda esta historia, es que si bien Putin quería
asegurarse de que la guerra de Ucrania no creara
potenciales rivales, al final terminó facilitando
que propio líder del grupo Wagner se hiciera
muy popular. Tan popular que a comienzos de
año ya había periodistas y analistas que lo veían
como todo un candidato a suceder al propio Putin.
Podemos decir que Prigozhin
se pasó todas las pantallas y
adelantó a la inmensa mayor parte de
los gerifaltes y oligarcas de Rusia:
Había hecho mucho dinero, había logrado
muchísimo poder, tenía un ejército privado
y encima empezaba a ser bastante popular… Tanto
entre el ejército como entre la sociedad rusa.
(Su meteórico ascenso comenzó en el
verano del 2022 cuando recorrió las
prisiones rusas para reclutar prision rusos,
ha hecho regalos a sus viudas y a sus madres,
y sobre todo ha dicho verdades sobre la guerra
que nadie más se atrevía a decir en Rusia.)
Asimismo, haber puesto en la diana de sus feroces
críticas al mismísimo ministro de defensa,
Serguéi Shoigu y al Jefe del Estado
Mayor, el general Valery Gerasimov,
le ha sido de gran ayuda para ganarse la imagen
de ser un guerrero efectivo e independiente. Todo
un portavoz de la Rusia fuerte y grande que Putin
siempre defendió pero ahora parece hacer aguas.
De esta forma, durante el 2023 Prigozhin se
ha preocupado cada vez más de representar y
defender los intereses de los soldados rusos.
Probablemente esta popularidad es la razón por
la que nadie en el Kremlin se haya atrevido
a perseguirle… pese a su insurrección armada
Fijaos por ejemplo en lo que decía ya en enero
de 2023 el periodista ruso Mikhail Zygar:
C2 (26 de enero de 2023: En un futuro próximo,
el Sr. Prigozhin puede desafiar al presidente,
y es posible que el Sr. Putin ya no pueda
oponerse a su ex chef. Mikhail Zygar)
Toda una premonición, ¿no os parece?
Claro que Prigozhin puede no ser el
único ni tal vez el principal
candidato a suceder a Putin.
¿Queréis conocer más nombres? Pues… Atentos.
T3 (¿QUIÉN PODRÍA SUCEDER A PUTIN?)
¿Quién podría suceder al emperador?
Esta es probablemente la pregunta más
importante y al mismo tiempo
más difícil de responder.
Pensadlo bien, si hace 6 meses nos hubieran dicho
que Pregozhin, también conocido como el “Chef de
Putin” iba a traicionar al presidente ruso,
probablemente no lo hubiéramos creído. Y, sin
embargo, todos vimos como sus tropas y vehículos,
incluyendo algunos tanques, avanzaban hacía Moscú.
Pues bien, exactamente lo mismo
puede ocurrir en otro momento con
otras muchas personas… Un jefe de la guerra, un
oligarca importante, un militar de alto rango o
simplemente un burócrata algún burócrata
que hasta ahora ha pasado desapercibido.
Desde luego, si Putin cae, no será porque
él voluntariamente decida jubilarse en
su mega-palacio del mar Negro. Que por
cierto es este que veis en Google Maps.
Pero, no nos desviemos. Si Putin se
jubila, no será por voluntad propia
sino por obligación. Por las buenas
o por las malas. Y ahí puede surgir
cualquier nombre. Y desde luego el del propio
Yevgeny Prigozhin podría ser uno de ellos.
Sin embar go, las elecciones rusas
están como quien dice a la vuelta
de la esquina. Se tienen que
celebrar en marzo de 2024.
Así que si os parece hagamos un pequeño juego.
Supongamos que el régimen actual consigue
mantener el control a toda costa y que los
actuales círculos de poder en torno a Putin
quieren mantener, precisamente eso, su poder.
Supongamos, por último, que llegan a la
conclusión de que Putin ya está muy quemado y
que necesitan una cara nueva. Ojo, no parece algo
tan descabellado. Con tantos fracasos políticos,
militares y económicos, esta puede ser
una conclusión bastante lógica. Cambiar
la cara del mandamás antes de que otros
quieran cambiar el régimen al completo.
Por supuesto, esto es todo una enorme conjetura,
pero es una conjetura, que puede sernos muy útil
para saber qué nombres podría ver sobre la mesa.
Es decir, cuáles son los nombres que hoy por hoy
suenan con más fuerza o parecen más probables
para llevar a cabo una transición continuista.
Por ejemplo, ahí tenemos a Nikolai Patrushev,
que es amigo de Putin desde su época como
agente de la KGB. Actualmente, es secretario del
Consejo de Seguridad de la Federación de Rusia.
¿Su mayor handicap? Mantienes posturas
muy radicales sobre el mantenimiento de
la guerra en Ucrania. De hecho, hay quienes
alegan que es uno de sus máximos promotores.
Otro nombre podría ser el de Dmitri Medvédev.
Medvédev ya fue presidente florero de Rusia
entre 2008 y 2012 para que “Putin” pudiera
seguir mandando sin saltarse los límites
que fijaba la Constitución. Es un tipo muy
próximo a Putin y es bastante más joven:
57 años frente a 70. Actualmente, es el
Vicepresidente del Consejo de Seguridad de Rusia.
Sin embargo, Medvédev tiene
dos problemas: por un lado,
su popularidad y su imagen quedaron
muy tocados al verse envuelto en un
macro caso de corrupción que desveló
el líder opositor, Alexei Navalny
N1 (El ruso Medvédev, vinculado a un imperio
inmobiliario de mil millones de euros. DW)
Qué sí, que todos sabemos que Rusia y corrupción
son prácticamente sinónimos, pero peso a ello,
¿qué queréis qué os diga? Eso de ver que el
Primer Ministro tiene un montón de palacios,
dinero y utiliza constantemente, los helicópteros
del gobierno para sus asuntos personales
no da buena imagen… Ni siquiera en Rusia.
Por otra parte, en los últimos años,
Medvédev ha dado un giro de 180 grados
a su discurso. Si antes era conocido como
todo un moderado, ahora se dedica a amenazar
a diestro y siniestro con el uso de armas
nucleares. ¿Queréis una prueba? Pues… Fijaos.
N2 (27 feb, 2023: Medvédev afirma que
el suministro de armas a Kiev podría
provocar una catástrofe nuclear mundial. Reuters)
N3 (23 de marzo de 2023: Medvedev afirma que
crece la amenaza de una guerra nuclear. AP)
Así que tampoco parece el mejor recambio,
al menos para recomponer las relaciones
con occidente y volver así a vender gas
y petróleo a Europa como si no hubiera
mañana mientras los grandes oligarcas
se pasean por el mundo billete en mano.
Luego, en términos institucionales, el actual
Primer Ministro Mikhail Mishustin es el siguiente
en la línea de mando. Sin embargo, procede
del Servicio Federal de Impuestos. Es decir,
este es un tipo al que Putin colocó en esta
posición precisamente para que gestionara
el gobierno de forma algo más tecnocrática.
Pero lo cierto es que no parece tener mucho
capital político. Así que, por ahora, lo
siento Mishustin, pero estás descartado.
Luego hay un nombre que podría ser toda una
sorpresa… Dentro de una cierta continuidad.
Hablamos de Serguéi Kiriyenko, que ya fue
Primer Ministro de Boris Yeltsin en 1998.
Actualmente, no tiene aparentemente
mucho peso político y ni siquiera
tiene un puesto en el gobierno. Dirige Rosatom,
la empresa estatal de energía nuclear de la
que ya os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
(A Kiriyenko se le ve con un perfil más
reformista, tiene buenos contactos en
occidente y parece tener también la simpatía
de los altos oficiales de la inteligencia rusa.
También tendría buenos contactos entre muchos
de los poderosos silovikis de los que ya os
hemos hablado un montón de veces. Ya sabéis
políticos y altos funcionarios que proceden
precisamente de las agencias de seguridad, y que
hoy forman un anillo de poder en torno a Putin.)
Es decir, que si los círculos actuales de poder
quisieran mantener el control de Rusia y al
mismo tiempo lograr dar un cambio que sea
capaz de modernizar el país y mejorar las
relaciones con el resto del mundo, este
podría ser su hombre. Y, ojo, que cuando
llegó al poder Putin no solo era relativamente
desconocido, también llegó con ese mismo encargo.
Pues bien, estos son 4 de los nombres más
destacados qué tenemos que tener
en cuenta. Al menos 3 de ellos.
Pero como os hemos dicho, también podría ocurrir
que la caída de Putin fuera provocada por algún
acontecimiento repentino o por la llegada
de un nuevo círculo de poder. En ese caso,
por supuesto el nombre escogido
sería alguien completamente distinto.
Claro que, esperad un momento,
porque quizás estamos vendiendo
la piel del oso demasiado pronto.
Hay una pregunta que todavía no nos hemos hecho:
¿Podría intentar Putin
volver a consolidar su poder?
En cierto modo, esta sería otra
alternativa a la situación actual:
Putin podría coger al toro por los
cuernos e intentar consolidar su poder
y volver a ser el Putin al que todos
imaginamos montado encima de un oso.
Sin embargo, para poder hacerlo,
el líder ruso necesita dos cosas:
primero conseguir acabar con la
guerra de Ucrania sin sufrir una
derrota y segundo lanzar una enorme purga
política al mejor estilo estalinista.
¿Por qué? Pues porque, las purgas no
solo sirven para acabar con díscolos
y disidentes, también para demostrar mano dura.
Algo así fue, por ejemplo, lo que hizo, el
predecesor de Putin, Boris Yeltsin en 1993,
cuándo el país estuvo al borde
de la guerra civil. Fijaos.
(En septiembre de 1993, Yeltsin estaba
contra las cuerdas, su gobierno era un
desastre y no estaba consiguiendo
ninguno de sus grandes objetivos.
Para cambiar esta dinámica ordenó disolver
el Congreso de los Diputados del Pueblo de
Rusia y el Sóviet Supremo de Rusia porque
estaban frenando sus reformas económicas.
Sin embargo, el Congreso rechazó el
decreto presidencial y por contra
aprobó la destitución del presidente. Los
legisladores se atrincheraron en la Duma
y Yeltsin respondió utilizando su mejor
arma de negociación: el poder del fuego.
La Duma fue bombardeada y
desalojada por las fuerzas
militares. Al final Yeltsin impuso su voluntad.)
La situación actual es muy diferente, pero
en cierto modo podemos ver un patrón común:
Si quiere continuar al frente de Rusia,
Putin tendrá que dar un golpe en la mesa,
acabar con cualquier disidencia y restablecer
su poder de una forma muy visible.
La pregunta es, ¿será capaz de hacerlo?
Los últimos acontecimientos sugieren que
su posición ya no es tan fuerte. El hecho de que
no haya podido castigar la insurrección armada de
los Wagner es buena prueba de ello. Y, ojo, porque
esta es una idea muy extendida en la propia Rusia.
C3 (26 junio 2023: Hoy he escuchado la declaración
de Prigozhin. Es esencialmente un llamamiento a
continuar la rebelión y un intento de presentarse
a sí mismo como un hombre blanco y tranquilo.
Estoy sorprendido e indignado por el hecho
de que el traidor y rebelde siga en libertad
y pueda continuar con sus actividades
anti-estatales. Sigue trabajando para sus
enemigos y para la derrota de Rusia en la guerra.
Viktor Imantovich Alksnis, Ex miembro del Soviet
Supremo de la URSS y exDiputado de la
Duma Estatal de la Federación Rusa)
Para colmo, todo apunta a que
la guerra en Ucrania seguirá
castigando su posición con más y más
bajas, nuevas derrotas y un ejército
que cada vez estará más harta del
presidente y sus megalómanas ideas.
Así pues, si Putin no ha podido
utilizar todo el poder de su
fuerza contra la insurrección del
grupo Wagner no está claro que lo
pueda hacer en el futuro. Pero si no
lo hace eso podría acelerar su caída.
Dicho lo cual y llegados
hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Creéis que Putin logrará dar un golpe en
la mesa o por contra la situación de Rusia
hoy se parece más a la de la Unión Soviética
de 1991? ¿Cómo de cerca pensáis que está el
fin de Putin? Déjanos tus respuestas
en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Si os gusta lo que hacemos no olvidéis
darle a like, suscribíos a VisualPolitik,
y si queréis más sumaros a nuestra comunidad
de Patreon. Nos ayudaréis a mejorar y además
recibiréis un montón de contenido extra
y también merchandising exclusivo.
Un abrazo enorme. Nos vemos en un
próximo vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik.